[拍手]
こんにちは
今泉進むです
3年前私はアフリカを陸路で一周しました
それもトラック移動キャンプ生活の旅です
陸路での旅はいつも楽しいものです
現地を自分の味で歩きその地域に住む人と同じ3戦で世界を眺めることができるから
です
私が旅したアフリカの国は28カ国
アフリカにある国のおよそ半分です
およそ10か10か月をたかけて旅をしたのですがそれでもわずか半分の国しか旅する
ことができませんでした
旅のルートは二部られ大会今日からモロッコに当たり今度はケープ大変
なんかします
今度はケープタウンからずーっと北に上がっていき
ジプとの回路がゴールです
私はこの旅の記録を
アフリカさるく彦
というブログにまとめることにしました
さるく
とは私の地元長崎の方言で歩いて回るという意味です
英語で言うと大きいがラームという薬を当てたいところですがそれとはちょっと異なり
ます
もっとキョロキョロしながら歩いてもある
どちらかというと1ジョインに近い感覚でしょうか
さて今日は私がアフリカを去るいて見えた
グラデーションについてのお話をしたいと思います
その前に私がなぜまずアフリカに興味を持ったのかについて話さなければなりません
なんでアフリカなんか勉強してんのなんでアフリカのことやってるのって今まで行くだ
となく惹かれてきました
この質問されるために私はいつも答えに窮してしまうのですが今日は遠い記憶をたどっ
てその答えを少しだけ見つけてきました
一つはこれ
私が小学生の頃日本と韓国でワールドカップがありました
当時社会科の授業でその出場国について調べる授業があったのです
私のクラスメイトたちはイタリアやイングランドドイツやブラジルといったサッカーの
有名国について調べていました
ですが私はなぜかこの国カメルーンについて調べていたんです
今となっては全く思い出せないのですがただ他の人と少しだけ違うことをしたかったの
だと思います
それから中学校に進学すると
地元ホークスの大ファンだった私はプレ秋に熱中していました
特にその当時活躍していたバルデスやつレイター
といった黒人選手に憧れることになります
それから高校に進学すると陸上競技部に所属していたこともあり当時活躍していた
ケニア人ランナーたちに憧れました
そこで一冊の本と出会うことになります
ケニア彼らはなぜ速いのかという本です
この本にはキニア人だんだんの進退的特徴だけでなく彼だが生み出される社会的背景
経済的な面そして歴史的な名まで深く
網羅されていました
この本から私は黒人選手は賢者人ランナーといったスポーツ選手だけではなくそこから
広くアフリカを知りたいという思うようになりました
これが高校1年生の時ですその時すぐに私はスワヒリ語専攻に入学しようということを
決めました
そしてその時もう一つのものと出会うことになります
それがオーバーランドでの旅です
なぜオーバーランとか当時テレビ番組でやっていたからです
あるテレビ番組でカイロからケープタウンまでアフリカを1104日間で縦断する
オーバーランドの旅についての特集をやってみました
私はこれを見て俄然興味を開きました
特にキャンプしながらゆっくりとゆっくりとサビしていくつかスタイルに憧れたのです
よくよく調べてみるとこれアフリカ縦断だけではなくアフリカ一周の旅もあるという
ことで私はこれに参加しようということも決めました
こうした overland ですかもう少し私の中には理由があります
一つは私が降りか乗ってねらリストになりたいということでした
1つの特定の地域に専門特定の地域の専門になるのではなくアフリカ大陸に広く知って
いる
物知りになりたかったんです
そのためにはアフリカの一つの国ずーっといるだけではなく広くゆっくりと自分の目で
アフリカを見てもある必要がありました
もう一つは私の地元の方言さるく
にも代表されるように自分の足で見て回りたいと思ったからです
それがこちらあして学ぶという理由です
この2つのことができるそれがオーバーランの旅でした
さてそのオーバーらのために出るのに2つの準備がまた必要でした
一つは私は学生ですお金がないんです
だからお金を集めなければなりません
もちろんアルバイトもしましたがもうひとつクラウドファンディングをやりました
クラウドファンディングが最近インターネット上でお金を集める方法として注目されて
います
そしてこのクラウドファンディングをやるにあたって必要だったのが私の旅のテーマを
決めることです
私は旅のテーマを自分の専門でもあるアフリカの歴史にしました
じゃあ具体的に何をしたかというと
旅した各国でその家の教科書を集めていったんです
特に歴史の教科書社会科教科書を中心に集めました
それからその各地に住んでいる人にとって歴史ては何ですか
いやあなたの持っている歴史観は何ですかのような質問をたくさんしました
そうして教科書と現地の人の聞き取りからアフリカについての歴史を学びました
皆さんのアフリカのイメージはどこでしょうか
私はこの旅に出る前すでにアフリカについて学んでいたのである程度の知識は自分でも
あったというふうに思っています
しかし一般的にアフリカって均一的
泊まれていないでしょうか
同じような人が住んでいて同じようなものを食べて
そして気候も同じように熱い
でも実際それは違います私が旅したスーダンは53度を超える灼熱でした
一方モロッコの高山地帯やアフリカの最高峰タンザニアキリマンジャロの山頂まで登っ
てみると氷点下です
この基本さを均一的と表現できるでしょうか
それは違います
アフリカは多様的だ多様性があるところだというふうに言われるのです
アフリカを少しでもかじったことがある人もしくはアフリカ大陸を旅したことがある人
そういう人はこれにとても共感できると思います
ただし私はこれにもう一つ加えたい
単に多様性でバラバラでいろんなものがあるだけではなくそこに
グラデーションがあるんです
半に違うだけじゃない同じところもあるそれがゆっくりとゆっくりと変わっていく
それが見えるのは私の旅でした
その一つ
青色の町モロッコのシャウエンです
この中央のいえばモロッコのシャウウェイの一つの街角です
私はそこで出会ったベルベル人男性にこう言われました
この水色この青色はベルベル人の信仰の対象であって水の青であり空の青なんだよと
こうしたベルベル人のムラサ上野町
こちらはエジプトの街です
モロッコとエジプトそれはサハラ砂漠を返して遠く離れていますが同じ様な水色が使わ
れているのです
ちなみにこちらはベルベル人ではなくヌビア人の家です
彼らが話す言語そして文化
しゃべっていることはもしくは食べている物っていうのは若干違うのですがそれでも
この青い色というのは共通した分割して残っているんです
コースたグラデーションなんでできるんでしょうか
その正体は一体全体何なんでしょうか私はもう少し考えてみることにしました
その一つがこちら
大型の家畜がいないことです
腹砂漠より南には熱帯病があり大型の価値こうシークするのが困難です
例えば楽だ
ラクダはサハラ砂漠ではもちろん飼育ができますが
サハラ砂漠以南になると熱帯病でシークはこんな
また長距離移動に適した馬も飼育は困難です
それに加えて大型の二年はアフリカ大陸ではなかなかできませんでした
その代わりこうしたダウ船
というような帆船が長らく使われてきました
こうした船で1ヶ月や2ヶ月をかけて
東アフリカからインド洋へと旅立っていったのです
こうして大きい船が作られなかったりもしくは大型の家畜が使われないとどうなるか
人が歩いて移動して社会が作られていくのです
もちろん牛やロバヤギやヒツジといった家畜はシークできます
ただしそれらの家畜は長距離移動には適さないようです
こうやって僕が同じスピードで文化が作られたようなスピードで
猿行きみたからこそ分かった少しエピソードを紹介したいと思います
それが食べて感じたグラデーションです
こちら真ん中の写真はガーのふふという料理です
この白色のビニール袋に入っているのは夫婦という主食になります
こちらはヤムイモやキャッサバを粉末にしてそして沸騰したお湯で溶いて練ったもの
です
これをこんな日中なんかにつけて食べることがあります
ちなみにこちらがは南アフリカの
パップという食べ物です同じように白色です
ただ資源量が違いますこちらとうもろこしです
味も少し違って
こちらのふふ距離はもっと味がある感じそしてちょっとだけザラザラしています
さらにこちらまた見た目は同じです
こちらトウモロコシかられてきています南アフリカのパップと同じです
ただしこちらのほうがより淡白な味わいです
なんとなく自分の感覚とシェア鹿児島のかるかんにいたような感じがします
まあこうした似たような食べ物があるんですけど
味も違うんですよねそしてその発行のさせ方なんかも違ったりして
中にはこういう同じような形にこういう粉を練ったものでも酸っぱい物とかもあったり
します
これがアフリカの面白さです
同じようなものを使っているように見えてもそこにグラデーションがあるんです
さてキャンプをしたことがある人なら誰でもわかりだと思います
その地にキャンプをしたからこそ4面の凹凸が分かるんです
もしくは風の音が分かるんですもしくは木のにおいや
地を這う生き物を見つけることができるのです
こうしてキャンプして旅しながら感じたグラデーションについて今度はお話ししたいと
思います
その一つがこちら
鍵屋から一応 pi とずーっと北上して行った時のハイライトです
まず犬やから一応ぺー少しだけ旅をしていくとまだまだ緑が広がったところが見えてき
ます
まだここに至る前の段階です
そこではまだ濃厚が行われています
それよりもさらに北に行くとだんだんだんだん
牛やヤギの大量の水群れを見つけることができます
100棟や200頭単位で飼育しているのです
それからさらに北上していくとまた乾燥していきます
そうすると今度はこちら
ラクダの群れに出会うことになります
は管の群れに出会ったときは壮観でした
なぜなら牛というのはあまり見たことがある人もいないかもしれませんが人間と同じ
くらいの高さです
ただし楽だとなると完全に見上げてしまいます
それぐらい大きなラクダの6でとても迫力があります
そこから腹に北上していきます
そうするとどうなるか
もう一度緑が増えてくるんです
そしてまた牛の群れに出会うことになります
ただし先ほどまでの牛の群れとは異なります先ほどは100頭単位での牛の群れでした
今度
じっとぐらいです
同じものを飼育していてもその飼育方法がだんだんだんだん旅するにあたって変わって
くるんです
こうした家畜のグラデーションや自然のグラデーションもアフリカを旅する面白さです
さて私は皆さんにこうしたグラデーションを感じてほしいのですがちょっとアフリカに
行くのは困難だという人が多いと思います
もちろん私の希望としては皆さんにアフリカに行ってほしいです
ただそういうわけにもいかないので旅をしてみてください
日本国内でもいいんです特に田舎の方がいいと思いますね
否かを旅してその土地に暮らしている人に話を聞いてください
まあ単なる世間話から始まってもいいですでもちょっとだけ深い話を聞こうとして
ください
そこにあるべきしってなんですかとかここ独特の食べ物とかここ独特の文化って何です
か
ってちょっと聞いてみてください
ってそれだけで終わりじゃないんです
それからちょっとだけ足を伸ばして隣町へ行ってみてください
また同じ事をしてください
そうするとそこに少しグラデーションを感じることができると思います
さあそれさえも億劫だという人がいるかもしれません
そういう人はもうしょうがありません
今度は基礎工学部と理学部の間に立ってみてください
もしくは文学部や経済学部の間
まあ石橋か蛍池の間にもどちら目ですまぁそこに立ってみるとですね
そこに行き交う人がいるので必ずグラデーションが見てとれるんです
きっと理学と基礎工学部にいる人の彼は違うと思います
語っていることも違うと思います
その違いに耳を澄ませてください目を凝らしてください
遠いアフリカでも
もっと近い自分の身の周りの世界でも
グラデーションを見つけられるかどうかは全てあなた次第です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]